ouais ai-je déjà tué quelqu'un la
réponse est non moi ai-je dû dormir
quelqu'un pour obtenir des renseignements
la réponse est non quelle culture
veut toujours un bel espion c'est un vœu pieux
de la part d'une grande
population masculine américaine population mondiale
de penser que les espions féminins correspondent à cela
modèle
[Musique]
J'aime dire aux gens que c'était un
peu comme mi6, c'est q nous étions les
gadgets techniques de la
communauté du renseignement américain, nous avons fait toutes
ces choses que vous voyez dans les films, le
but du déguisement était large et profond,
vous vouliez  pour se fondre dans une foule, vous
vouliez être la petite personne grise dans
l'ascenseur dont personne ne se souvenait être
monté et dont personne ne se souvenait être descendu vous
vouliez ne pas être remarqué quand j'entrais
je suis entré en tant que secrétaire
et à l'époque presque toutes les femmes qui
travaillaient dans le  La CIA est arrivée dans une sorte
de poste de bureau, il y a toujours eu
cette idée qu'être une femme était un
désavantage et les hommes ont certainement ressenti
cela
et il y avait un groupe de femmes
avec qui j'étais qui pensait qu'être une femme était
peut-être un avantage dans ces
scénarios opérationnels parce que vous pouviez vous
déplacer si facilement, que ce soit un
cocktail diplomatique et que vous
parliez à l'ambassadeur de n'importe où
et qu'il baisse sa garde parce qu'il
parle à telle ou telle femme peut-être que vous
pourriez obtenir beaucoup d'informations que
le  les hommes ne pouvaient pas simplement parce que vous
n'étiez pas menaçant cela a très bien fonctionné
pour les femmes sur le terrain une fois que nous avons été
autorisés à nous mouiller les pieds, il est devenu
difficile pour moi de regarder une
partie du matériel d'espionnage qui est sur le film que
je viens de commencer à regarder  la patrie
parce que la quarantaine me manque le personnage
dans la patrie de Carrie eh bien c'est un
personnage beaucoup plus réaliste que l'on
voit très souvent dans la culture populaire elle
n'aurait pas elle n'aurait pas été
tolérée à la CIA elle ne suit pas
les règles qu'elle se fait  ses propres règles, elle
prend toutes sortes de risques, elle prend Dieu
sait quels médicaments elle prend parce qu'elle
a clairement des problèmes de personnalité,
la façon dont les femmes sont représentées, les femmes
connaissent-elles le service
[Musique] [
Musique]
Hollywood avait des capacités qui nous
avaient toujours intéressés  en fait,
quelques autres choses que nous avons faites, nous avons d'abord
vu dans les films, puis nous avons décidé
que c'était une idée amusante que nous ferions aussi,
alors nous sommes d'abord allés à LA pour le
maquillage pour le maquillage et le travail
avec des masques parce que  John Chambers a attiré
notre attention en raison de sa création de
cette technologie de masque dans le film Planet
of the Apes l'original qui n'était qu'un
morceau de notre conexión
l'autre morceau était avec la
communauté magique à laquelle nous leur avons parlé et a dit que vous
savez que nous sommes  en regardant comment vous mettez en place des
illusions et des tromperies sur scène, nous
aimerions mettre en place
nos propres illusions et tromperies, mais la scène va
être à Moscou qui a été le
début de toute une entreprise
déguisée qui a eu lieu à la CIA
[Musique  ]
Tony Mendez Je l'ai rencontré en Extrême-Orient lors d'
une fête de Noël à l'ambassade américaine il
avait eu trop de punch qui avait
été fabriqué par nos chimistes OTS mais ce n'était
jamais la recette a été confisquée le
punch était hors la loi il n'a jamais été servi
à nouveau  c'était Tony c'était notre première
rencontre c'était mémorable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Américains une série télévisée J'ai vraiment aimé ça
J'ai vraiment aimé le regarder c'était aussi
proche de la réalité que j'avais vu au
cinéma cette idée que c'est un  l'espionnage
est un travail c'est un c'est un travail quotidien
cela a un impact sur chaque aspect de votre vie vos
voisins vos amis tout ce
dans quoi vous étiez impliqué j'ai eu une
reconnaissance instantanée en regardant cette émission